Cela fait maintenant sept ans que je fais des vidéos sur cette chaîne YouTube ! Vous en avez pas marre de voir ma gueule quand même un peu ?
En 7 ans j'ai appris ÉNORMÉMENT de choses !
Comment avoir des abonnés, comment faire des vues, comment avoir un corps séduisant- non ça pas tellement ça. Aujourd'hui je vais partager mon savoir avec
vous dans une vidéo intitulée....
"Comment apprécier la pièce de théâtre de Tex ?"
Non.
"Comment devenir un YouTuber célèbre ?"
"Première astuce"
Les amis premier conseil c'est quelque chose d'indéniable
Foutez vous de la qualité de vos vidéos. MAIS C'EST VRAI ! Parce qu'avant de voir vos vidéos qu'est ce qu'on va voir ?
Une miniature et un titre !
Et si ça, ça n'arrive pas à convaincre la personne, alors votre vidéo n'arrivera jamais jusqu'à ses yeux.
Bien travailler son titre et sa miniature c'est très simple. Si vous avez pas trop d'inspi vous pouvez utiliser la technique W.A.F pour la miniature. Pourquoi W.A.F me direz vous, car c'est l'abréviation de White-contour/ red Arrow/ Shooked Face. Et je sais, j'ai pas mis toutes les lettres
dans l'abréviation, ça n'a aucun sens. Vous le savez, cette recette marche à tous les coups, vous jouez à un jeu vidéo un lapin saute un peu haut...
Oh !
Ce lapin a des ailes !
Ça a du sens. Dans le YouTube Game, ça a du sens. Vous allez alors faire un contour blanc autour du lapin et des ailes,
mettre une flèche rouge vers celui-ci et ajouter votre tête avec une expression de choquée de l'autre côté de l'image. C'est pas trop mal, c'est pas trop
dégueu, mais qu'en est-il du titre ?
qu'est ce que vous captive le plus ?
"Ce lapin a des ailes" ou alors ;
"CE LAPIN A DES AILES" ou alors ;
"CE LAPIN A DES AILES ?" ou alors ;
"CE LAPIN A DES AILES ?!?!?! Et bien c'est une bonne chose nous sommes d'accord.
Pour faciliter la chose n'hésitez pas à faire un shooting photo de vous-même faisant différentes expressions. Ça va vous servir pendant 2/3 ans et
vous aurez plus besoin de le faire.
Faites juste attention à pas vieillir entre temps parce que sinon ça va commencer à se griller
*voix blasée* Bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo nous allons aujourd'hui parler
...Bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo/Et n'oubliez pas de toujours mettre votre visage sur les miniatures je veux que les gens ne voient
que ça en ouvrant YouTube ! Savez vous vous avez déjà vu les visages que vous voyez dans vos rêves ? Car votre cerveau n'est pas capable de concevoir des visages
Qu'il n'a pas vu auparavant. Je veux que les rêves des gens soient remplis de votre visage OK ?! Vous croisez une dame elle a votre visage !
Vous croisez un vieux ? Il a votre visage ! Vous croisez un chien ? Il a votre visage ! C'est à ça que ça sert !
Manipulez le cerveau des gens Allez y !
"Deuxième astuce"
N'oubliez jamais ce pourquoi vous avez commencé YouTube... LA TUNE !
Si les op s'enchaînent et que les gens vous soupçonne d'être un vendu
ne paniquez pas, vous aurez encaissé assez d'argent pour acheter de faux avis sur des sites de merde- sur des excellents sites- ces avis positifs
Ces avis négatifs décrédibiliseront la minorité d'avis négatifs qu'il y a en dessous de votre vidéo. Ces gens vont alors se remettre en question avoir des jours voire des semaines
douloureuses en se demandant pourquoi ils pensent différemment des autres ,pourquoi ils ne suivent pas la masse, et tout ça grâce à votre intelligence.
"Et la troisième astuce."
Buvez une bonne bouteille de Saint-Pellegrino
chaque matin avant de tourner ses délicieuses bulles pétillantes vous permettront d'avoir les idées claires et de produire de belles vidéos
"Quatrième astuce."
Un autre truc que j'ai remarqué depuis tout ce temps, c'est l'importance de garder la même coupe de cheveux du début à la fin alors
oui si vous avez commencé YouTube très jeune vous êtes un peu pénalisé on va pas se mentir mais si vous avez commencé un peu
plus vieux comme Antoine Daniel ça passe très bien en découvrant YouTuber pour la première fois on ressent un feeling particulier envers sa coupe de
cheveux les mois et les années vont passer vous allez changer mais votre coupe de cheveux va rester là même en retournant sur vos vidéos, l'abonné
va donc ressentir une nouvelle fois ce feeling particulier qui va lui rappeler la fois il avait découvert cette coupe de cheveux des années auparavant il
est donc destinée sans même s'en rendre compte à être accro à votre coupe de cheveux et avoir une dose d'endorphines
monumentale à chaque vidéo de vous.Pourquoi ai-je gardé la même coupe depuis des années ce n'est pas par plaisir
c'est par stratégie nombreux sont les YouTubers qui ont compris ça mais ne veulent pas partager le secret contrairement à moi
les salauds. de plus vous serez beaucoup plus facilement reconnaissable dans la rue le nombre de photos vous prendre avec vos fans va considérablement augmenter
et cela est très bon pour votre égo et pour devenir un gros fils de-
"Cinquième astuce."
les commentaires négatifs vont arriver en même temps que le succès et oui tout le monde ne peut pas vous aimez même si vous êtes
fantastique. Les commentaires haineux vous blessent mais ce n'est rien à côté des critiques constructives qui part de la vérité et qui vous frappe en
plein coeur. Pas de panique vous êtes sur la bonne vidéo j'ai la solution cliquez sur l'onglet communauté,cliquez ensuite sur l'onglet paramètres de
la communauté, ajoutez des modérateurs qui pourront supprimer les commentaires négatifs
avant que vous les voyez. Finies les mauvaises journées à penser à ces mauvais jugements en scrollant vers le bas vous passerez devant tous les
utilisateurs bannis de votre chaîne. Wahou,
ils sont nombreux. mais l'encadré qui nous intéresse est l'encadré des mots bloqués. marquez dans cette encadré tous les mots qui sont susceptibles de contenir
une critique négative
j'aime pas, c'est nul, pourri, naze, tu as changé, bof
moyen, bisous
grâce aux filtres et aux modérateurs,les critiques négatives ne vous atteindrons plus jamais vous serez alors réconforté dans l'idée que vous êtes
le meilleur, le plus beau, et le meilleur créateur de la plateforme YouTube
félicitations.
"Sixième astuce."
Si malgré tout vous perdez votre confiance en vous, ça peut arriver on a tous des mauvais jours.
Regardez une compilation de vous qui rigolez.
Vraiment. Il m'a fallu cinq ans pour trouver la solution et c'est juste après  que ma barbe s'est mise à pousser. Une réaction
d'égocentrisme surpuissante est envoyé dans votre cerveau et vous redonnera immédiatement confiance en vous vous êtes le meilleur,
ne l'oubliez pas. Attention tout de même à ne pas vous surprendre de rire de vous-même qui riez.
Ou alors peut-être que vous rirez de vous même qui riait de vous-même qui rit.
"Septième astuce."
Le fait de copier un autre est totalement diabolisé on appelle ça, le plagiat vous n'avez plus d'idées, plus de créativité,
ne vous en faites pas.Cherchez sur YouTube une chaîne espagnole ou anglaise, mais pas trop connue; il ne faudrait pas que le public français
la connaisse.Commencez  alors à copier coller ses vidéos sans aucun problème.
Si votre public commence à s'en rendre compte, ne paniquez pas référez-vous à l'astuce numéro 5.
ça marche à tous les coups.
"Et c'est la huitième astuce."
Ça va vous paraître loufoque mais n'hésitez pas à péter en pleine vidéo.
Cela montre que vous êtes détendu et que l'ambiance est bon enfant.
Aussi vos abonnés verront là un message ; Oseriez-vous péter devant autre chose que de très bons amis ?
Non.
Alors si vous pétez devant vos abonnés, cela montre que vous les considérez comme de bons amis ils s'en rendront compte et vous aimeront encore
plus.
"Neuvième astuce."
Quand les gens commenceront à se lasser de vous mais pas de votre coupe de cheveux comme on l'a dit il leur faudra un nouveau
visage, un nouveau représentant de votre chaîne
ADOPTEZ UN ANIMAL.
tout le monde l'a fait c'est très important pour réussir quoi de mieux qu'un animal pour incarner le renouveau de votre chaîne ? Un chien,un chat,
un Pug, un Shiba peu importe. Cela montrera que vous aimez les animaux
si vous aimez les animaux vous aimez la nature si vous aimez la nature vous êtes une bonne personne
n'hésitez pas à ouvrir un compte Instagram en son nom et à y pratiquer le placement de produits de manière à rentabiliser le coût de
l'animal. *rires*
"Dixième Astuce."
N'hésitez pas à aller faire votre pub sur d'autres chaînes mais faites-le intelligemment ! commencez votre commentaire en vantant la vidéo "J'ai adoré ton court métrage,
bravo !"
C'est trop vague, il pourrait s'agir d'un spam que vous mettez sur toutes les vidéo. "Tu joues de mieux en mieux la comédie et les
blagues sont fluides et naturelles."
à ce moment précis et où l'on croira que vous êtes un viewer sincère et pas mal intentionné vous en profiterez alors pour diriger les
gens vers
votre chaîne YouTube,car vous êtes le meilleur "je fais moi aussi des courts métrages sur ma chaîne"
à ce moment précis ça fait beaucoup trop pub
il faut montrer que votre intention est bonne et pas méchante, que vous êtes à la recherche de quelque chose de significatif et pas de
chiffres. "n'hésitez pas à venir me dire ce que vous en pensez pour que je m'améliore"
Bingo ! Les gens auront envie de jouer les chevaliers blancs et de venir vous réconforter dans l'idée que vous êtes le meilleur
et ce qu'ils savent pas, c'est que vous êtes le meilleur.
"Onzième astuce."
vous connaissez très bien les pseudos des gens qui ont beaucoup de clics, vous savez qu'en utilisant le pseudo de gens connus vous
allez pouvoir ramener une partie de leur communauté sur votre vidéo. Votre frère a une barbe et porte des lunettes ? "mon frère est Cyprien." non qu'est-ce
qu'on va a dit là ? "MON FRÈRE EST CYPRIEN ?!" vous tuez un ennemi sur Fortnite, et il se trouve qu'il s'appelle "Amixoum"
Mais attendez- "JE TUE AMIXEM SUR FORNITE ?!?!"
"Douxième astuce."'
Personne ne peut savoir le fonctionnement exact de l’algorithme de YouTube. Pour quelles raisons
met-il telle et telle vidéo en avant et bien nous ne le savons pas mais tout le monde suppose que c'est un mélange de
"watch time" qu'est ce que le watch times quel pourcentage de la vidéo va être regardé en moyenne par une personne qui est tombée sur
cette vidéo exemple je fais une vidéo de 10 minutes en moyenne les gens regardent seulement deux minutes de cette vidéo. Ah, c'est mauvais mais
comment faire pour tricher et forcer les gens à regarder votre vidéo jusqu'au bout bien qu'elle soit de piètre qualité ?
"regarde jusqu'au bout fils de pute"C'est non, bien sûr que non plus subtil plus malins soyez malins.
Les réseaux sociaux chers amis. Faites croire
à l'utilisateur qu'il y une surprise à la fin de la vidéo et qu'il a tout intérêt à la voir car elle est importante ;
"Bonjour les amis je viens de sortir une nouvelle vidéo regardez la bien jusqu'au bout il y a une petite surprise
Jusqu'au bout hein !"
est ce que le nombre de commentaires ne reflètent pas aussi la qualité d'une vidéo et donc la mise en avant du youtube de ces
dernières ? Et bah si alors faites genre que vous les lisez tous ! "N'hésitez pas à commenter la vidéo je suis en train de lire tous vos
commentaires et ça me fait très plaisir je les lis tout ils sont tous là je suis en train de tous les lire alors n'hésitez
pas hein !"
vous êtes si intelligent ! Mais peut-être que l'algorithme se base aussi sur le nombre de j'aime d'une vidéo "Et on n'oublie pas
le petit pouce bleu hein  pour soutenir le pouce bleu !" Ou alors il se base au nombre de fois ou la vidéo a été
partagée ! "Quand on est un bon abonné on partage la vidéo hein, sur les réseaux on la partage hein"
*cris*
DES ABONNES DES ABONNES !
Vous venez d'atteindre 10 millions d'abonnés bravo et maintenant ?
(silence)